maurice pialat police est ce que c'est
un polar oui oui j'aime pas beaucoup
l'expression de l'art m'enfin ça couvre
un peu beaucoup pour une chose en temps
oui bien sûr florange et sais pas je
t'en colle à l'ailé qui disent que vous
l'avez réinventer savez vous devez vous
êtes bien placé pour ça si on entend les
critiques où il y aurait un
chef-d'oeuvre sinon par jour mais en
tout cas par semaine alors que et en
particulier dans cinéma je pense que
celle saura enfin d'ailleurs on me dit
pas on dirait cinq heures avant qu'elle
polar non parce qu'il est différent
c'est tout mais ça en fait il ya des
règles il ya les personnages qu'on a
l'habitude de rencontrer dans ce genre
de film puis voyous avocat fille sait
c'est assez des personnages et c'est
voulu c'est pas un hasard si des
personnages qui sont qui sont ravis du
répertoire si je puis dire
et pour la première fois en fait de vos
films c'est pas un film autobiographique
dr tient finalement unistar s'arrêter
mais mes films ya deux films que j'ai
faits ils sont tous vus rafik sur huit
seulement effet en équitation de loisir
qu'on dit que vous mettez beaucoup de
vous deux vous dans vos films là dans
deux mais pas dans les six autres n'ont
rien de moins dans les six autres et
mangin c'est quand même un peu vous
aussi oui parce que jean gérard dis
amicalement d'ailleurs que il s'était
inspiré de moi mais ce qu'on peut
ce qu'on peut oui bon bah c'est de toute
façon c'est flatteur
oui et non puisque mangin n'est pas un
homme particulièrement c'est pas moi
comme flic il a des défauts comme sommes
aussi sais pas je veux dire c'est moi
particulièrement flatteur d'apprendre on
le ressent montfort effectivement il ya
peut-être un peu de moi m'avait ya aussi
beaucoup de gens et puis c'est tout que
c'est quand même un flic même si on a on
a vraiment c'est très attention à ne pas
essayer de prendre des flics autour de
nous et de l'est les dépeindre c'est un
personnage complètement fictif vous
servait souvent des faiblesses qui peut
y avoir dans dans les scènes que vous
tournez parce que j'ai marqué par
exemple que dans un dialogue
gérard depardieu se tromper dit cite une
phrase de chardonne je prends les dix
tout le fond le fond des choses c'est
toujours pour y oui et il se reprend
midi le fond des choses c'est toujours
horrible
est-ce que vous avez gardé cette scène
là parce que c'est bien vous dites oh
pardon je sais bien vous disiez ça va
j'ai compris un jeu c'est bien vous dis
ça parce que vous êtes appelés moufles
et blesse je vois pas où il ya une
faiblesse non parce que bon dans la vie
il arrive de se tromper souvent on fait
les citations souvent fausses en plus un
personnage n'est pas forcément le
représentant du moteur qui sera
quelqu'un qui se trompe jamais
d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr que la
rectification aussi exact parce que moi
je les entends dire je suis lecteur de
chardonne mais je ne les ai pas lues de
mes yeux lui cette phrase chardonne
maurice pialat merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau et longue vie à police
merci